this video is sponsored by hong kong
impact third
from the makers of genji impact mihoya
are back with another update from their
other game
hong kong impact third honkai impact is
an action rpg that you can play on
mobile or pc
and plug i don't need to say much more
mihoya have been pushing the boundary
for mobile games for years now the
combat system is fast paced highly
satisfying and i mean just look at how
good it looks
right now the captains of the global
server are welcoming you with an
anniversary celebration you can get
amazing rewards of over 40 supply cards
and also receive the hershey of the void
and her exclusive weapons for
free she's one of the most powerful
queens in the game and all you have to
do to get her is just participate in the
event
not only that but honkai have also added
another character
the herscher of sentience she's got a
sword whip
and spear that you can swap between and
her old does massive aoe damage while
activating a special form where she can
unleash a barrage of blows which can
stun her targets and
also she's hot and lastly the developers
have given
everyone a gift for the lunar new year
in the form of this beautiful new skin
it's available to everyone participating
in this event which only lasts for a
limited time so if you haven't tried out
hongkai impact third already
then all you need to do is click the
link in the description to give it a go
today
and with that said let's get on with the
video
live novel titles even if you've never
read a single light novel you definitely
know when you're watching an anime
that's adapting at light novels because
the titles are [ __ ] stupid that time
i got reincarnated as a slime
reborn as a vending machine now i wonder
the dungeon
well damned what will you do at the end
of the world will you
save me well you i can't actually
remember the title name that's so
[ __ ] stupid most people think that
when making a good book or movie title
you should think of something short
snappy and memorable that encapsulates
everything that the story is about
that's the smart thing to do right [ __ ]
that trying to be intelligent
that's pretty cringe bro why would you
want to waste brain cells thinking of a
clever title when you can just make a
sentence long synopsis and just make
that the title and that's exactly what
light novels did i remember a time when
light level titles weren't like this
when it was normal to have titles like
barcano and spicenwolf and the word
isekai wasn't invented yet
but over the years they've just gotten
progressively longer more ridiculous and
more stupid
so stupid in fact that you know what i
bet even a [ __ ] robot can make better
titles
[Music]
now look i know meaning on light novel
titles is not a new thing for the anime
community
there's just a certain way that light
novel titles are structured that makes
them sounds like
light novel titles as opposed to titles
for any other medium
like can you imagine if george orwell's
1984 was actually called
i'll rebel against the totalitarian
states but anichan is watching me
or if the bible was just called the
melancholy of jesus christ oh man i'm
definitely going to hell for that one my
favorite part of that series was the
last book the reappearance of jesus
christ that volume's a [ __ ] banger
right i'll [ __ ] stop but what is it
about light novel titles that make them
sound like light novel titles like i'm
sure i'm not the only person
who's been describing themselves or
their day and in the process
just accidentally made a light novel
title something like
i was filming a youtube video but then i
realized i hadn't done the washing
i told you to do that yesterday one easy
way to think about it is that you can
just make some kind of stupid sentence
in the first person perspective and just
fill in the gaps with different words
so you can theoretically make a light
novel title generator using this theory
all you have to do is create a basic
sentence structure like
my adjective family member can't be this
adjective
or i was verb as a noun and now i live
as a job title
in this place name and then all you have
to do is fill in the gaps with words
like another
world princess dungeon reincarnated
and bam you've got a brand's new eso
guide there's already a few mimi light
novel title generators which i think
use this basic principle but the only
reason they work is because
i recognize the sentence structure
because well
i'm a human what i wanted to see is if
an ai could essentially replicate this
without having me telling it
this is what a line level title sounds
like and going further beyond that
would an ai be able to make a title that
could fall a real human
into thinking that this was a real light
novel so
here's the plan number one make some
kind of ai learning program that could
make
convincing light level titles without
having me or any other humans telling it
how it's done number two find some lab
rats i mean friends
and then test them to see if they could
tell the difference between a real
human made light level title and an ai
generated one
i thought this was a fantastic idea that
was super interesting and i couldn't
wait to try it out
i had just one small problem
i know absolutely [ __ ] all about ai
luckily by complete coincidence i asked
my patreon discord server to see if
there was anyone who could help me out
and by complete chance one of my patrons
happened to be a software engineer who
specializes in
ai man i really wrote the ssr catcher on
that one say hi fabi hi
all right enough about him with this
help we decided to use gpt2
as a base an ai made by openai
a research organization founded by elon
musk
so why gpt2 well gpt2 is a highly
complex ai
that can translate texts summarize
passages answer questions
and even create text outputs that can
sometimes be indistinguishable to a real
human and also it's free so how does it
work
well the gpt architecture implements a
deep neural network in which input is
processed by multiple layers of neurons
whose weight determines the activation
patterns of subsequent layers
and the final layer of neurons
constitutes the output of the network
this means absolutely nothing to me i'm
just reading the wiki article
basically you can think of the ai kind
of like a brain with it being just a
highly complex statistical model that's
made up of millions or billions of
parameters
that kind of acts like neurons in a
brain
is that right fabie i mean that's a very
of a simplified way of putting it but
as long as it makes me sound smart now
gpt2 was trained to learn english by
feeding its millions of data sets from
around the internet
from wiki articles to reddit posts to
news articles
to tweets too i really hope they didn't
feed it for jan oh
god can you imagine if an ai realized
its own sentience through the internet
and his first thoughts were pain peko so
you have this very complex ai model that
theoretically knows
english and english grammar and sentence
structure and
what are we gonna do absolutely [ __ ]
ruin it
because we're going to feed it light
novels man imagine firing up 1.5 billion
neurons to learn english only to be
taught how to make shitty isekai titles
so on top of the base program we can
train it with a specific data set to see
if it can replicate
any patterns within that data set in our
case we took the entire bookwalker
dataset and just fed it
all the light novel titles within that
data set this video isn't sponsored by
bookworker but thank you daddy
bookwalker and thus
she was born the title recommendation
autonomous systems hierarchy
trashbot and here she is trashbox 3000.
i said trashbox tonight but yes this is
it i don't know what you're expecting
you know i have this image that i said i
was making an ai program and the first
thing people thought was oh god
giggles making the next skynet that will
bring about the end of the world through
anime titties no
guys it's a [ __ ] exe program that
outputs text files
it's not that exciting but yeah this is
the first time i've seen it i haven't
played around with it at all yet
fabi did say and i quote i can't be
asked to fix this user interface so
you're stuck with this window size he
didn't really say that i'm just [ __ ]
with you
so instead we are just going to copy all
the titles this makes to a text file
where we can read them all now like i
said i haven't played around with this
at all yet so
this could just output complete
gibberish really hope it doesn't because
then this would be a really boring video
but yeah i don't think there's anything
more that needs to be said so
let's just jump into it you know i did
trust fabby a lot with this
he could have just put a virus on my
computer and i would be
none the wiser all right let's uh let's
let's see what we got let's see what we
got
what the [ __ ] is this first result
sister wolf in the closet how to become
a molester i'm so
good what
oh god what have i created i don't even
know how to describe that is god even a
real word
or did the ai just make this up let me
let me check
nope it literally just made up a word
you know i'm really glad that this has
been made by an
emotionless ai because i already could
see twitter cancelling this light novel
already even though it doesn't exist
brilliant off to a great start you know
this one doesn't actually sound too bad
tales of the magus and the beast lord of
the bizarre kingdom awakening of the
seven stars this sounds almost generic
enough
that i would ignore it if it was an
anime adaptation okay this one actually
legit almost sounds like a real light
novel title
sorceress summon in another world my
little sister's marriage is a dream to
reincarnate as an elf
you know what that's pretty damn good
unfortunately one dead giveaway though
is when the ai obviously took one of the
big franchises and tried to make its own
title the hero's tale of the commonplace
demon lord the ancient magus of harahi
suzumiya i think this is three different
franchises stitched into one
this is literally just a frankenstein
light level title and then there are
some which just make
absolutely no sense like in another
world a certain magical index item is
become unique in another world
kyoto princess which is the magical
index item
[Music]
i am the strongest in the world as a
villainess a fake detective agency
i tried to pick up girls at birth
good evening pedophiles what the [ __ ] i
tried to pick up
girls at birth
[Music]
oh god i didn't think we could find
new levels of illegal but i think we
just did you know where'd you even go
after this
are people gonna be exposed and you twit
longers in 10 years being like
yes your honor i was still a
single-celled organism when he tried to
slide into my dms
[ __ ] did i just describe cells at work
you know one thing i'm noticing is that
i don't know why this is but it seems to
have a problem with repetition sometimes
because you've got titles like cold
focus black clover black clover black
clover clover black clover
no it's not even quite clover it's black
cover all right let's try this again
cold focus black cover black cover black
cover cover black cover blue cover black
cover blue cover and then it's something
like this
kuma kuma kuma bear kuma kuma bear to
the lost world
does someone want to tell the ai that
kumar literally means bear
literally just made a title called bear
bear bear bear bear
the lost world but you know what if it
keeps it simple enough then it can
actually find a pretty generic title
sometimes like
my big sister lives in another world and
just
adding a [ __ ] ton of exclamation marks
and question marks at the end now i
think we succeeded in
making some pretty stupid light novel
titles but we can do better i want it
to be able to make really convincing
titles so
even though we can't affect how the ai
program learns
we can fine-tune it a little bit so we
can edit things like
the minimum title length it needs to be
in the maximum title length it needs to
be
and also we have these values called top
k
and top p now to try and explain this in
the most simplest of terms you got top
k now with top k you know the function
on your phone that sometimes recommends
the next
word it thinks you're trying to type out
and it gives you a certain amount of
words to choose from
that is the top k so the higher the top
k is
the more word choices the ai has to
choose from when it's constructing a
sentence
and then you have top p and this chooses
the quality of the words and
i'm not really sure how to explain it
simply without losing a bunch of you but
to put in the most simplest terms the
higher the number of top
p the less likely it is for the sentence
to be grammatically correct
that's a very oversimplified way of
looking at it but i'm going to try and
fine tune it to see if we can actually
get some good light novel titles alright
you know what just by fiddling around
with it i've already gotten
way better results already it's not
completely off the rails but
some of these could pass as real light
novel titles i swear to god i mean you
got pretty generic ones like
the world's finest shooter again good i
feel like this just needs a bit more
fine tuning with there i'll be the
master of death
survives in a leading character of
average sex
i've read some stupid light novel titles
like that i don't know if i'd be able to
tell the difference between
this and a real light novel title you
know i'm actually going to start a new
notepad
of titles that i think might actually
sound like real lightning titles yes
just like alice in wonderland
the story of a magical girl and her
princess you know what
that's that's that's going on the list
that is going on the list you just made
the list
my little pony series the miss cat of
the seven deadly sins
where the hell did they get my little
pony from where they gotta check is my
little pony on the line novel list that
we fed it how the hell did this ai come
up with my little pony god this actually
makes me a bit worried because that
means
how many my little pony articles did
gpt2 have to go through when learning
english
oh god i'm so sorry oh my god valvrave
valverie what are you doing here how did
palfrey find its way here
all right dynmachi fans we found the
newest dunmati spin-off this time
following the villains pov
i'll never let you try to pick up girls
in a dungeon
all right gentlemen you've heard of
interspecies reviewers
well get ready for inter-species
catastrophe
all right we've gotten to the point
where i think we can make some pretty
interesting light novel titles that
don't actually exist because now it's
giving me stuff like
classroom girl the strongest little
sister lives in a fantasy world which
sounds stupid and generic enough to
exist okay so getting to the end of this
tweaking what i've noticed
is if the title has a reasonable word
count in it
it makes some pretty damn convincing
titles crazy in love with another
world's hero
yup that could be one you just made the
list the secret of 6
trillion years in the fantasy world
honestly
this actually sounds like an isa guy i
would like to watch you just made the
list
if you're in a relationship with a girl
you've got a really nice girl
okay now we're just getting into basic
sentence construction
this isn't a light novel title this is
just the most
ai generated compliment i've ever heard
this shouldn't be a light novel title
but it should be at least a fake quote
people die when they are killed
the archer class is really made up of
archers if you're in a relationship with
a girl
you've got a really nice girl
like it'll sometimes [ __ ] out things
like papa molesta part 2 the world's
strongest and most interesting fake
friends
which i'm not gonna lie just sounds like
an ugly bastard isakai hentai god i
didn't need to put that in my head
i was reincarnated in another world now
i became a villainess
isn't that an actual title oh okay
that's what it was called
[Music]
i literally can't tell the difference
between real existing light novel titles
and ai generated ones now you know i'm
actually going to put this on the list
i'm going to see if people can actually
remember that this
isn't a real existing light novel title
now another thing we can do
is we can choose what word the title
should begin with
so you can put any word you want or more
preferably
you can even put your name and see what
titles trashbot comes up with
with your name inserted so let's give
that one a go
oh my god
well i think i found a small hitch in
the program
um it'll only take the first word
and put it in a title if it actually
recognizes that word as a word so i
guess most of this is just the ai
trying to figure out what do you do with
a word like giggup
giganagatri so it's somehow just taken
my name
and put it as one of the monogatari
series gigan's big brother lives in
another world as a child
is this why i'm an only child gigguk
you've got sober girls in a dungeon
what are you insinuating that i do
oh no sydney sunny come here
what do you think of this title as a
light novel no
no i wonder if it recognizes garnet's
name let me see this
all right it doesn't seem to recognize
gantt as a name either
great i wonder if he'll recognize his
name if i put grant
i hate my life of course it recognizes
grant as a name
that's what everyone thinks my name is
every time they first hear my name
anyway all right so apparently my real
name is useless to try and make a light
novel title out of using this ais but
luckily
i have two friends who have way more
common names who will also be
judging the validity of these titles so
let's try them
joey the anime man let's see what it
comes up with
well of course it knows joey's name
doesn't know my name but of course it
knows joey's name alright joey's
apparently comes up with some of the
most generic sounding light novel names
i've heard of
joey and the wholesome princess i don't
think that's how you spell wholesome
joey's big sister is a girl the archer
class is really made up of
joey bisner isn't that really close to
joey's actual name
did trashbot just figure out joey's name
joey biz
how i got naked in another world
that's just joey's name
oh joey i always knew you were a fan
service harem protagonist all right
let's see what connor comes up with of
course it recognizes conor's name as
well
connor and the killing of the clumsy kid
oh god connor what have you been doing
you know i'm actually a bit salty
that most of these actually make sense
and most of them is actually really on
brand for connor as well
connor is a catastrophe in another world
yeah he definitely [ __ ] would be
connor and the harsh mistress of the
city that doesn't sound like a title
that just sounds like a chapter in his
life
connor and the dopist wives of harsh
mistress summersex
oh no he's actually found his dream
title
he's the main character for milf hentai
connor wants to be a hero but it's
actually a dick
[Music]
part two i'm not the world's strongest
gamer
how is that so accurate but so stupid
all right
we're stopping there we're not gonna get
a better one than that
how does trashbot know that connor's
such a toxic gamer
look at this connor humanity's strongest
gamer part two
it recognizes conor as a gamer but not
gant as a name
and i think that's everything now i have
my list of light novel titles from
trashbot
that i think sound pretty decent in
different levels of complexity
so the next step is to actually test
these
with connor and joey so here i am now
with the boys
hey guys future giggup here so i
actually made this experiment a full
quiz for the boys but it goes on for a
full
26 minutes i'll be releasing that as a
separate video but for the purposes of
this video
these are clips from some of the
questions which i think highlights the
full results of trashbot's efforts
so basically what we're going to be
doing today is we're going to be playing
humans versus robots you both are on one
team so
if you guess correctly then the humans
get a point oh okay
if you lose then the ai gets the point
right
we have to like agree yeah well that
never happens
so first one is uh real or fake so
you're gonna be given
i have a bunch of titles and i chose
like simpler
sounding titles so this is more on
concept right
does this concept sound like a real
light novel title okay i was born as a
dragonite but i am your maid oh sorry i
was born as a demon knight but i am your
maid
that sounds fake am i going to be doing
this again right again
there's one point about this where i'm
thinking that this is real but this
could also
easily be the ai just learning and
that's the fact that it ends in a period
because there's been like this common
trend recently where
light novel titles especially it's like
it's not just a title
it's a [ __ ] sentence right and it
ends
in a period i i think this is too real
it's not it's not weird enough oh i mean
i think you're like
you're giving too much credit to libels
i feel like a lot of them have even
weirder things than this and this is too
straightforward no i think
i think the quirk i think the quirk is
the fact that like you know
he was born as a demon knight this
really powerful thing but at the same
time
it's a demon knight well it's like it's
a knight that also has demon powers
right
and i am your mate i could see it being
real i could also see it being fake
but i think i don't know i'm really like
this period man
like you're also fake no i'm gonna say
it's real it's fake
the ai is too smart it's too normal
that's what i mean like
there's no like i [ __ ] my my
ten-year-old sister on a trampoline you
know
your view of lionel was just [ __ ]
whack that's what they all sound like to
me
you know the unwanted virginity of a
genius i want to read this
if it's real what does this mean what
does this what does this mean this
doesn't make any sense i don't know
wants to no one wants his virginity
wants his virginity because he's a dick
maybe
uh i i feel like this is real or or or
either the protagonist is is like you
know has a friend who's a genius and
doesn't want it it's just insanely
enough or i'm like japan would make this
yeah this this seems like a real one
it's fake
[ __ ] honestly i've i've read this title
i
i've read this i'm like i want to read
this yeah this this actually
sounds this is a super legit title right
i mean can i
can i write this down because i read
this i'm just like
that sounds like a really unique like
rom-com right yeah
it's like a genius and he's he doesn't
want his virginity that's that's how i
took it yeah yeah yeah
right yeah he's a genius and he doesn't
want his virginity because but but none
of the girls won yeah but none of the
girls won him that's that's how i read
this yeah
so we're changing up the game a little
bit okay so those were
the um those were like the shorter
titles right those i i
shortened the titles yeah those those
were the shorter titles okay yeah
i can believe that so now i tried to
train the ai to make
longer titles you see some of the like
longer more convoluted light novel
titles
i wanted to see if there was a method to
the madness if there was
any logic between some of the really
batshit crazy stupid titles
right so you're gonna be given two
titles and you need to tell me which one
is the fake one and which one is the
real one okay okay
seriously seeking sister ultimate
vampire princess just wants little
sister plenty of service will be
provided
that's gonna be safe gravitation
war chronicle an exiled wizard princess
another chronicle for raising mobs
that's gotta be fake that's rad reads
too poorly
which leads me to believe that that's
real vampire princess just wants little
sister semicolon plenty of
service will be provided what the [ __ ]
is you you i feel like you underestimate
the stupidness of life titles i do think
that's real i this one this one reads
so bizarrely the thing is though when i
look at both of these and i'm thinking
of like
the japanese cover of it yeah i see this
being more of a reality than this one
all right i'll go with your gut then
i'll okay if i'm wrong
then i revoke everything i just said but
i feel like the left one is the real all
right fine we'll hear that then
you're right yes it's so
dumb i like how the i like how you got
to this by
saying which one makes the least amount
of sense yeah you know but this one
makes too much sense that's what i'm
saying
i feel like i feel like it's hard to
teach a computer to make
just the right about yeah that's i mean
that's that's kind of why i wanted to do
this because i'm just like
it's such a specific kind of broken
reading that isn't broken but it
it's just nowhere near natural crimson
princess
is not a witch too a night at the end of
days the complete story of the world's
strongest dungeon
okay i'm a behemoth an s ranked monster
but
mistaken for a cat i live as an
elf cat elf girls pets yeah i just read
so like so many light novels yeah this
one's this is really like
yeah this reads like a lie no this is
fake the bot deserves a very big one of
applause
this is so good that i would believe
this is a title crimson princess is not
a witch
a knight the s-rank monster is what's
really convincing yeah
it's real i think that that's something
that i would be super that is a hundred
percent anesthetic
yeah i would be super impressed if the
bot knew how to do that yeah
all right yeah god feeling i'm gonna say
that right one is real me too
okay um you are correct but yeah you're
correct
yeah ranked monster thing seems like
such
weird because it's yeah it's such
bizarre knowledge that only like a gamer
would use
yeah yeah and that was it thank you very
much joe and connor for helping me out
with that
if you want to check them out i mean
come on you know you know it is you know
who they are already links in the
description
so what did we learn well first and most
importantly
a highly complex and sophisticated ai
doesn't recognize gantt as a name
[ __ ] my life but also an ar is more than
capable of making convincing light novel
titles and concepts
as long as that title is confined to
about a sentence or so
and it can make some pretty interesting
ones as well like the unwanted virginity
of a genius
someone needs to make this a real thing
this sounds like an amazing harem
rom-com
i would pick up from title alone like i
need to know
how this genius goes about losing his
virginity however
what i find interesting is when we get
to the more longer and convoluted titles
there's this really subtle method to the
madness that we see
with real light novel titles and
whatever that convoluted logic was
and ai wasn't able to grasp it like
if anything the ai made titles made too
much sense
which i find absolutely fascinating if i
had more time to put into this
i would love to see how the ai handles
japanese names because then we'd have a
far
larger database to feed it and also we
wouldn't have to worry about weird
translations being a factor
and secondly we use gpt2 when
gpt-3 exists but this is only available
to a select few who actually apply for
it
and um i don't know if openai really
wants their hard work to be used for
making shitty sakai titles
but if we were able to get access to it
it's meant to be a way more complex ai
that's way more sophisticated that uses
a far
larger number of parameters than gpt2 so
maybe just maybe
it'll actually acknowledge my [ __ ]
name yeah conor gets to be an epic gamer
and joey gets to be a harem protagonist
and what do i get a [ __ ] auto
correction
thanks skynet
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again
thank you to hong kong impact 3 for
sponsoring me today if you want to try
out their game and get all the good
freebies that you can get by trying out
their event you can click the link in
the description to download it today
and also i want to give a huge thanks to
fabi for helping me create trash bots
and
really making this video possible you're
the real mvp today fabi
i really don't know what i would have
done if you weren't a patron of mine
this is also a completely new style of
content that i'm trying out so i
really do actually hope you enjoyed what
you watched and hopefully i want this to
be
just the beginning i have way more wacky
ideas that i don't have the expertise
to be able to make happen so if you are
some kind of expert in your field
whether that be in the sciences
like physics chemistry biology or
whatever
or just engineering or you know what
even if you're someone working in the
fashion industry
i'd love to actually hear from you so
you know what if you are some kind of
expert in your field whether
it be in the sciences or the engineering
or you know what
even if you've like worked in the
fashion industry before or anything else
wacky
i'd love to hear from you because i
don't know how to make some of these
ideas i have a reality and
honestly in some cases i don't even know
what kind of skill sets i'm looking for
that was a vague enough shout out right
like
i don't even know if this is going to
lead to anything but anyway that's it
from me for today
i've been giggup and i will see you all
next time